go ahead let's give it a shot what do
you say to Americans who are upset with
you over the way you downplayed this
crisis over the last couple of months we
have it very much under control in this
country the corona virus is very much
under control in the USA it's going to
disappear it's like a miracle it will
disappear if March 4th we have a very
small number of people in this country
infected March 10th we're prepared we're
doing a great job with it it will go
away just a calm it will go away what do
you say to Americans will be that you
got this wrong and I do want them to
stay calm and we are doing a great job
if you look at those individual
statements they're all true stay calm it
will go away you know it you know it is
going away and it will go away and we're
gonna have a great victory and it's
people like you and CNN that say things
like that that it's why people just
don't want to listen to CN anymore you
could ask a normal question the
statements I made or I want to keep the
country calm I don't want panic in the
country
I could cause panic much better than
even you I could do much I would make
you look like a minor league player but
you know what I don't want to do that I
want to have our country be calm and
strong and fight and win and it will go
away and it is incredible the job that
all of these people are doing putting
them all together the job that they're
doing I am very proud of the job they're
doing that Mike Pence is doing that the
task force has done that Honeywell and
Procter and Gamble and Mike and all of
these people have done I'm very proud
it's it's almost a miracle and it is the
way it's all coming together and instead
of asking a nasty snarky question like
that you should ask a real question